it's time to expose the most disgusting
part about Sam bankman freed and the
fraudulent FTX Sam bankman freed had
hundreds of meetings with the SEC the
regulatory body in the United States he
even worked extremely closely with the
chair of the SEC Gary gendler and these
meetings went on for months you have to
understand that FTX was about to
establish a regulatory Monopoly on the
entire crypto industry within the United
States and of course SBF has just been
found guilty on seven counts of fraud so
are we meant to believe that the SEC the
big bad major regulatory body in the
United States had no idea that Sam
bankman freed was stealing billions from
you and that his entire exchange was one
massive Ponzi scheme I don't believe it
I call BS I think that the SEC knew
exactly what was going on with Sam
bankman freed and FTX and in fact I
think that the SEC and Gary ginsa must
be investigated